hello everybody sorry sorry that we were a little bit late
today um i sort of went into the planet of the apes rabbit
hole i was i was reading up like i was oh my god oh i died
okay uh what the fuck what happened what what if okay okay
Mike like fucking okay apparently did not like that give me
a sec I don't know what happened I just it just crashed okay
where is that that was whoa that was awkward maybe it's the
quality oh no is this a fucking bitcoin miner Is this a...
Oh, no.
Is this a Bitcoin mining?
Alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
We're gonna see if it's a Bitcoin miner soon.
I put it on medium graphics to see if I'll fix it.
No way.
I'll be back very...
Oh, my God.
You know what sucks?
I worked so hard putting on my barista apron.
into coffee oh that's the worst part the fact that i spend
actually spend time putting on my uniform and then it just
fucking crashes oh this is bullshit this is actually
bullshit i have to put that bad shit back on come on i have
to put that shit back on okay um give me a sec guys grab my
coffee order too all right there we go okay I need a, all
right, let's try this again.
All right, that's a little awkward.
This is it.
Why is it?
Why am I not, why am I not up on the screen?
Hello?
Oh, there I am.
Okay, give me a second.
I put this back on.
I need it.
Give me a second.
I need to put this back on, everybody.
All right, let's see.
And then it was like right here.
All right, I think that was it.
All right, take off my i think take off my jacket i forgot
i'm not supposed to wear a jacket when i work uh i can't
wear my jacket when i'm at work my boss is gonna kill me i
can't they're like it's not appropriate attire apparently so
i have to take it off all right there we go okay there we go
that was i don't know what the fuck just happened there holy
shit i just crashed out of no all right anyway i'm back on
my uniform again and i have my uniform again uh yeah all
right there you go all right welcome welcome back don't
worry the barista is back i'm ready to do my minimum wage
job oh i gotta be grounded in reality i gotta know what it's
like to have a minimum wage job again so I can appreciate
you.
I can appreciate people more.
I know.
Anyway, welcome.
Welcome, guys.
For those who don't know, I actually have two really big
announcements.
I have two really big announcements to make today, but that
will be at the end of the stream.
So you gotta watch me work my minimum wage job before...
You gotta wait until my shift is over.
Before you can...
Figure out what the announcements are.
Yeah, yeah, wait until my shift is over.
I can't, guys, I can't announce when I'm working, guys.
Dragoons, I can't announce when I'm working, Dragoons.
My boss isn't gonna like it.
Dude, he's gonna dock my tips.
He's gonna take my tips, guys.
You don't understand.
I work like $4 in, wait, what's minimum?
I know they, like, did they increase minimum wage?
I know they don't usually do that anymore because like, you
know society, but like Not in Europe or Australia.
I know you guys get paid a lot better But like in NA they
stopped really raising the minimum wage these days to
account for inflation They stopped they sort of stopped
doing that.
So like I hope Is it it's like eleven dollars.
Okay, it's eleven.
Okay, chat That's dead.
Don't worry.
I'll revive chat.
Chad, don't worry.
I have coffee, chat.
We're going to feed you some coffee and then you're going to
be back to life.
All right.
Pew.
And then pew.
Okay, there we go.
Sorry.
We're today.
Today's a sort of special day for this announcement.
Um, but yes, welcome.
Welcome to Barista Simulator.
Um, you know, usually at usually at like 1230 p.m.
streams, I usually find some try to find some interesting.
games for 1230 they're usually called like one-off days
unless I've tried to complete a long series 1230 p.m.
is tends to be like one-off streams anyway I thought this
was really interesting I was reading the reviews and then
some of them was like this is stressful 10 out of 10 I'm
like you know what I need more stress in my life it's not
like I cried like yesterday because I was so stressed you
know what I think I need more stress I think I need I think
I need more of that oh my god anyway um apparently they're
saying like yeah these coffee orders tend to get like super
realistic so like good luck and I'm like yeah all right I've
never worked I honestly I've never worked um as well I cried
because like I needed to let it out because it's not good to
it's not good to like have it all kept up kept up inside you
like when you're really stressed out so i had like a nice
cry because i was like i needed to let it out and i was like
and then i'm okay now i'm okay because it's better it's
better than keeping it oh my god my pc it why is my pc
letting up so much hot air it's for risk this is not well
optimized this is not a well optimized game oh shit i i
literally i just booted this game up what do you all that is
a bitcoin miner this is definitely mining some crypto right
now for somebody in europe
Anyway, I'm giving some people some PTSD right now, wearing
my barista uniform and playing this game.
But you know what?
Let's try.
I've never been a barista before.
I've never done... I've never been worked as a barista
before.
So, like, this will be interesting.
I worked as... You know what I did similar?
I worked as an unpaid family member at a restaurant.
you know like you know it's like family-owned restaurants
and then you worked as an unpaid labor because your family
that's what i did so it's practically the same thing but
instead i said i just didn't get paid i didn't get paid i
got some free bubble tea at least my game crashed i think
it's barista simulator holy shit okay let me like let me put
her it as like the lowest graphics possible.
I think we gotta put this as the lowest graphics possible
for this game.
I don't think this game is meant to be played at all.
All right.
Whoa.
That changed a lot.
Oh my God.
We don't need shadows, guys.
Okay.
Maybe not like very low.
Maybe just regular low.
All right.
Maybe regular low should be okay.
Um, can't believe it this pc has a 40 80 i think or 90.
anyway um guys anyway if you guys want to know what the
announcements are they're pretty big announcements one will
be about what the special stream is tomorrow and the other
one is something else so um um you guys want to know what it
is yeah wait until my shift is over guys uh gladstone thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you you reckon I can
get this made to sing me a happy birthday also what were
what was that about plan the apes you were gonna say thank
you but super chat gladstone thank you thank you of course
happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear gladstone happy birthday to you yeah thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you anyway the reason why I was
late was because I was in the rabbit hole regarding planet
the apes lore so like uh
up about planet of the apes because recently i was watched i
watched the uh kingdom of the apes and like i'm okay this is
like spoiler this is like uh spoiler um but like i was like
okay um okay um there was this particular scene where they
surrounded the evil main character it was this is the ending
and it was like this particular scene where they surrounded
this evil main character Um, and then like, okay, and then
like the thing is, they could just push him because they
were at the cliff.
They could have just pushed him.
There was like, like 20 of them.
So, like 20 plus.
So I couldn't understand, like, why they just, like, we're
like, oh no, this one guy.
I was like, it's just one guy.
Push him.
And I couldn't understand.
they had to go instead they like called out for the birds to
like use the birds to push him so like i was just like what
why there's there's at least 30 of you what happened to apes
together strong it's not birds together strong it's apes
together strong so i was like incredibly confused about that
anyway i started i started looking up um sorry that wasn't
like that has nothing to do regarding the rabbit hole of the
kingdom of the hearts uh sorry the kingdom of the hearts
sorry i'm not talking about kingdom kingdom of the apes
that's nothing to do regarding why i was in the rabbit hole
but i just had to talk about the ending of that movie
because that made zero sense for me i was just like push him
it's one guy doesn't matter anyway um anyway sorry anyway i
was like really curious about the lore of like uh the lore
about like uh planet the apes and everything regarding the
newest series so i was like reading up like each character
and like getting to know about like like the society of the
planet also like i don't you guys remember but like plot the
not the original but the reboot of the Planet of the Apes
was like, was it 14 years ago?
Oh my god, why is this game crashing?
Oh my god!
Okay, maybe it's because I'm not playing the game, so then
the game boots me up because I'm not playing the game.
But yeah, the Planet of the Apes, the reboot of the movie
released like, oh my god, it released in 2011.
It was like 2011.
Did you guys know that Andy is like almost 70 now he's like
okay how old is Andy circus um he's like oh he's 60 years
old now and I was like oh my god he's 60 years old yeah holy
shit he's 60 years old that's the guy that does all the
animals like uh animals like uh 3d shit like know like golem
and everything and he always does like the tracking the 3d
tracking for for like oh like that moves weird um um but
yeah i was like so surprised i was like oh my god plan of
the apes is like 2011 there's oh my gosh speaking of 2011
somebody in my during like okay so like um Expo, during the
Anime Expo, Yusong sang a song that I like sang an anime
song and it was apparently a Boomer Anime song.
But like I didn't, like that's what like, that's what they
said.
They were like, I'm gonna sing a Boomer Anime song and I
didn't really know what it's from because like I have very
little knowledge of anime in general.
So then I was like, ha ha, Boomer, you're old.
And then like, and then so because I didn't really know what
the song was in general i was just like he he it's a boomer
song and i still don't i don't remember what song it was
again i actually don't remember and then no uh they sang a
solo song for by themselves for like anime expo for the
karaoke and then somebody like tweeted at us and was like
that's not old the show came out in 2010 and then i i didn't
call i i almost called them out in public because i realize
how long ago 2010 was i was like i i didn't call them out i
didn't call them out like i didn't name them out
specifically i almost did because it was on like twitter and
i almost was almost replied back 2010 was 14 years ago 14
years is long ago 14 years that's like the age where you can
create a twitch account that's like where you can finally
watch twitch streamers um 14 years ago is not guys i don't
know how 14 years ago is a very long time guys that's that's
where i'm like you you were born and then You're off to
middle school discovering girls or boys for the first time
Anyway, um, let's see, let's see, okay, let's actually try
and play this game.
I hope I don't actually crash when I'm playing, playing the
game.
Maybe it's the loading screen.
Maybe the start screen is like, okay, um, what should our
coffee shop name be?
realistic barista experience while managing and designing
your own coffee shop by all the equipment oh my god this is
basically like supermarket simulator but for like a coffee
shop um all right what is like a good what's a good coffee
shop name it has to be like super um super hipsters because
hip are hipsters still a thing are they still a thing or is
that like old now for like gen z alpha Dude, do the Gen Zs
know what hipsters are?
Shall Auntie Doki explain what a hipster is to the Gen Z
alpha?
Let's see.
Pretty sure it's...
Charco, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chab, you want to feel old.
Halo is considered a retro game because it's 20 years old.
um so like a hipster is what we used to call like people who
are like i used to like this before it was cool uh that's
what a hipsters are and hipsters tend to usually go to buy
very very expensive expensive mediocre coffee uh which is
what our coffee shop's gonna be today
there we go that's our shop oh wait no wait i got a better
name okay guys i'm gonna dismantle the shop again i'm gonna
dismantle guys i figure out a better name i'm gonna
dismantle the shop all right okay guys i'm gonna feel a
little adventurous i'm just assuming that it's the main menu
that's graphics are like super fucked up so i'm feeling a
little bit adventurous and i'm gonna put medium graphics it
might be justy it could just be the main menu guys Um, uh,
expensive coffee.
Please super chat.
Okay, that's a new name.
Okay.
Let's see.
Uh, all right.
Move your character.
Fill.
Pick up.
Oh, pick up and fill are the same thing.
Inventory.
All right, that's cool.
Wait, do I live here?
Do I live?
in my own uh enter the okay i need to turn down the
sensitivity the sensitivity is so fucking high uh sense all
right there we go all right okay entered okay i don't live
okay i live next okay that's my house okay all right okay
this is up okay
okay um all right guys i put all my life savings uh no kid
is going to college because i dipped into the college fund
to buy this coffee shop oh but there's free wi-fi i can
afford wi-fi and use useful features related to cleaning or
character management in the game by pressing the space bar
okay uh trash pin oh broom all right sweet sweet sweep sweep
sweep guys sweep sweep sweep okay increase the cleanest
level of the shop all right guys i dipped into the dragoon
college fun guys this is very important this is my lifelong
dream all right you dragoons are not going to college
because this you guys don't want me to follow my dreams
dragoons oh wait why the fuck is there a cigarette here okay
sweep sweep sweep to clean it oh shit how do i get this
broom away all right wait grab the trash how did i open my
trash can again oh my god how did i forget oh there you go
trash okay there you go all right your future that's don't
worry we're gonna make a better future guys we're gonna make
a better future for all of us you look we're gonna be so
rich thank you for the super chat thank you Thank you.
There's no coffee up.
Okay, use the chat.
Wait, did I not pick up all the trash?
Okay, there we go.
Guys, guys, you don't understand.
I'm going to be able to afford all your college tuition
after this.
We're going to take you to an Ivy League school with the
amount of money I'm going to make.
Turn on the fuse box.
Fuse box.
All right.
And then use the main computer for...
Uh...
Uh, Kate Barnes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got my bachelor years ago.
dip away that's why you're not getting a master's degree use
the main computer for caffeine management order a pack of
coffee beans and order a mini size coffee okay i can do that
all right you're gonna get wait can i not go a lower quality
i said buy good quality coffee uh all right we gotta get
mini coffee cup all right we only have what is it called a
grande wait what's the The small size There you go Han
George, thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you
Here's my college money, now I'm going To work at a mini
wage Job, thank you for the Super Chat, thank you Thank you,
oh, order an express so machine Alright, gotta dip into Han
George's college fund Express so Machine, nice, alright We
got the express so machine Alright, I should just Get the
cheapest shit and then overprice it You guys can't tell.
You guys don't know what good.
If you guys knew what good coffee is, you would make your
own coffee.
You would do homemade coffee.
You would not go to a coffee shop.
Like actual coffee snobs would make their own coffee.
Holy shit, my packages!
Is this Amazon?
I know, true.
If you actually know what good coffee tastes like, you would
not be going, wasting that money at a coffee shop.
You think I don't know?
Alright, let's see.
Install the machine on the table.
Rotate.
Alright.
Let's see.
You're going to go here.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Expression machines are industrial.
Fully automated machines.
It has many functions, but the most basic is extracting
espresso from ground coffee.
Guys, I need to open the window.
I'm already...
i'm i'm already overwhelmed
okay um more advanced have automatic milk of predators and
grinders to speed up your work come with it um to fill what
the fuck is what this mean oh my god dude i hope this makes
sense to people um um okay i think i think we can i think we
can do this i think i think we can do this all right let's
let's grab where's my box this is not my supplies am i
missing some more supplies What are we missing?
Oh, here we go.
I got to stack this.
Oh, I can't press a space bar to write the customer's name.
Oh, my God!
I can't write people's names.
Wait, that's so like...
Wow.
That's actually...
That's so interactive.
Okay.
How do I put this away?
Okay, there we go.
on the shelves uh place my one coffee bean that i can only
afford um any chance we get deep lore video about
transformers you know vows and spice all not that rich thank
you thank you thank you that's so cute i like that you can
actually uh do stuff open your shop oh my god who wants to
come to my shop we're open funded by my dragoons college
tuition all right hello what would you like okay take all
right and then right while holding press the space bar
what's your name lady hello what's your name liberty oh my
god don't worry i'm gonna draw you a nice picture there you
go it's like the statue of liberty there you go look at that
all right Here you go, Liberty.
I'm gonna make you your coffee.
I put that... I grabbed this.
I... No, that's the cup.
I... That's the cup.
Give me a sec, Liberty.
I...
Liberty, please.
Wait a moment.
Okay.
I grabbed this.
And then I...
I...
Filling.
You can use to transfer okay and then i i put the coffee bag
in i filled the coffee beans in the grinder i turn it on i i
pick it up i did i not is that not the what's the grinder oh
oh okay i filled it in okay okay there's the grinder guys
i'm learning i pick it up i grind grind grind grind oh my
god i'm figuring it out are you liberty look at me Liberty
are you enjoying this getting the first-hand experience none
of my dragons are going to college but I have a coffee shop
now um and then um thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you ma'am can I speak to you I am the manager I'm the
only person here um and then we fill it up
uh and then we put this down and we press the button oh no
we place this and we put it in and then place the shot glass
why would you need shots for coffee it's not alcohol guys
I've never made coffee before I just watch somebody do it
because I don't care because I'm not pretentious I just want
I'm JK I drink canned coffee I don't even drink regular
coffee I just drink canned coffee It's just so much easier
Is this not on?
Is it ready?
Is it?
Oh, it's doing it!
Oh my god, it's doing...
Oh my god, I'm so good at this.
I'm making God.
Liberty, are you seeing this, Liberty?
I know you have nothing else in your life
Liberty don't lie to me You have nothing else to do with
your life And you're paying $80 for a coffee From a coffee
store that just opened today With only one order Okay we
pick it up And then we put it We fill this in Did I fill it
correctly you want please is that it that's just that's it
shouldn't i put other stuff in this coffee she is college is
four years exactly coffee is forever coffee is gonna it's a
good investment everybody needs coffee because everybody's
too lazy to make their own um andy they give us a super chat
thank you thank you and a coffee is an addiction i should
put more she's happy she's happy guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
After using can you get rid of the coffee?
Why do we need to get rid of the coffee?
Isn't it like cooking?
We're like like the wouldn't it be like cooking you know
where like the essence of the coffee can like enhance the
flavor?
Like why would you need to clean the beans?
I don't understand.
Uh why would you need to invent like what do you mean Toki?
I'm just saying Like, wouldn't it work if...
How do I empty the knockbox?
Is this the knockbox?
Am I holding the knockbox?
No, I'm not.
Okay, I'm putting it back in.
Okay, the knockbox.
What the fuck is a knockbox?
What is that?
What is this?
What's a knockbox?
Guys, what is this?
Uh...
what what's the knockbox i don't understand empty it how do
i empty it empty the knockbox how do i how do i empty this
toss oh do i toss it in here oh but like i can just i should
just be able to toss a little bit and then like keep some of
it in to enhance the flavor guys you can tell never made
coffee before uh guys can you tell this is my first time i
usually don't order coffee i usually order a i usually i
usually i order like london fog or like i just drink canned
coffee if i order like a coffee order it's usually a latte
um uh let's see look at the coffee rest there's a coffee i
need to know the coffee recipe oh my god what do you mean i
need to know the coffee recipe
holy holy shit you know how london fog is so easy to make
you just get like earl gray and then you put like vanilla
extract that's london fog that's literally it like oh my god
okay espresso is very intense and espresso based okay that's
that's all right that seems doable the name means double
italian refers to a double shot for two espresso shot okay
i'm going to i what's the difference what what's what's the
difference it's just More coffee beans, right?
Yeah, it's 90, 60.
Okay, I can do this.
All right.
Oh, I can go home now.
One or we're one and done.
Family, I'm home.
I made $10.
Family, look at that.
Dragons, I made $10 today.
Are you guys proud?
out of me 500 oh my god guys i got a 490 dollar tip from
liberty i told you she had nothing to do with her life i i
fucking knew it i knew she had nothing to do with her life
if she came to this coffee shop hello what would you like
sir edwin you want a mini trip I got you sir.
How do I say yes?
Okay mini triplo.
Okay.
Uh, what's your name?
Edwin.
Okay, Edwin.
Um, okay.
Uh, I would like one red super for this.
All right.
We're gonna charge him a hundred dollars guys.
Okay, and then we're gonna put this here and then wait.
I don't Oh, there it is.
Okay, I pick it up.
I grind it.
Put it all the way up.
Grind, grind, grind.
Alright, grind, grind.
And then I put it in.
How do I fill it up?
Okay, I've picked this up.
And then I put it down.
And then I pick this up.
And I'll fill it up.
is that is that enough what was it uh triplo is triplo like
what was triplo again triplo is triplo it is 90 milliliters
oh my god what the fuck are you doing with your life all
right okay and then i put it in set the dosage as double
shot produce 60 milliliters set of 30 oh but i three so
that's mean i need like i need like i need to do like two
shots plus one okay and then go all right and that's do
another one two plus one guys i'm doing it i'm running my
own coffee shop okay hey edwin i know you also have nothing
to do with your life You a trust fun kid, Edwin.
Because why the fuck are you here?
Alright.
Guys, why does this take so long?
Does it usually take this long to make coffee?
Look at how excited he is for his coffee.
Yeah, he's so excited.
He's so excited.
Affiliate, I'm thanking for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
You can't say he really likes his coffee.
If he really likes his coffee, not be in this store he would
he would not he would not be here buying my coffee because i
bought the cheapest brand at walmart i bought the cheapest
coffee beans at walmart um all right and then we fill it up
that's like 60.
this is just one caffeine is that really all you want Oh, I
have to do it again?
Holy shit, what?
Okay, and then I put it in the knock box.
And then I have to grind it up again.
And you have to make another one.
Oh my god.
This is just a service.
I know the people at my coffee shop.
I know people at Tim Hortons does not do this.
Like...
the the staff members at tim hordens does not do as much as
i'm doing right now no edwin did you not like my story edwin
i can't do this fast you want a triple okay she was oh oh my
gosh lucky for you lucky for you um i i got I got a drink
for you.
Miss Gertu.
I can't do this faster!
What do you mean?
I can't do this!
I need somebody else to grind the coffee beans for me!
JP, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The real hipster coffee experience.
The bruce separating and judging the clientele.
Edwin had nothing to do in his life.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he would just leave All right, there you go.
Here you go.
Here's your coffee Is it not what you want?
That's a mini trip load.
Oh, I have to ring the bell.
Yay At least somebody's app.
Holy shit.
That was $140.
Can I like hire staff?
I need a level 2 store.
I'll get to level 2.
Oh, I'm almost there.
I need higher barista.
I don't want to be a barista anymore.
I don't want to be a barista.
You also want a triplo?
Oh my god.
I should have been grinding copies since the beginning.
You need fresh?
Is there not 60 in there?
Oh my god.
All right.
I'm fucking Oscar is not getting his coffee.
That's for sure.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I just want to be a owner.
I just want to be a coffee shop owner.
I don't want to be I don't want to do the hard work anymore.
Who would have thought minimum wage is so difficult.
I don't want to be a streamer forever.
Yes.
All right, pour, pour, pour.
All right, let's see.
All right.
We should latte art.
I'm sorry.
This is not an Asian coffee shop.
I don't know how to do any latte art.
All right.
Um, don't worry, guys.
I'm going to...
I'm going to fucking...
Oh, I grinded coffee.
I have a refill.
Don't worry, please.
Oscar, please.
Save for me, Oscar.
There's no decaf.
We don't serve decaf tension.
It's just coffee.
That's all we have.
Not even art in the cup.
Oh, my God.
I forgot to even...
Okay, I'm going to use this.
I'm going to pour this one in.
This is the only one I have.
Okay.
Okay, and then...
And then we're gonna put that, and then we're gonna pick up
this, and we're gonna...
Oh, please.
And then we're gonna throw...
No, it's full!
Oh!
Okay, escape.
Add inventories.
Pick up the item.
I have...
There's an electric one, too?
Oh, my God.
I need that.
Okay, and then...
And then we put...
Is this the bad coffee?
I think it is.
And then, Oscar, please...
Please say what...
me we're almost done with your order oscar please why does
everybody want a triplo i don't understand boom oscar please
i'm making the triplo as fast as i can oscar there's no we
don't sell hot chocolate gingerbread thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you all right thank you for the super
chat thank you thank oh my god i should start grinding more
coffee okay fill fill fill fill fill that coffee up and then
oh wait wait is it done Is this done?
I can't tell.
No, there's still 60.
I put that at one.
Oh, okay.
Oscar, please.
We're almost done.
Oscar, please stay with us a little longer, Oscar.
Okay.
All right.
Yay!
Okay.
What do I have to do?
Did I finish grinding it?
No, no, I didn't.
All right.
Grind, grind, grind.
Pick this up.
Throw it away.
No, lady, please.
I want to upgrade my...
store they don't need lens they're gonna drink it up okay
all right oh okay that's is that one that's oh my god i
don't remember the recipe i have two recipes and i don't
even remember the recipes already oh it's just a double shot
all right and then we're gonna pick that up boom There we
go.
All right, don't worry.
I got you.
All right.
What's your name?
What's your name, ma'am?
I'm going to call.
What's your name?
Madeline?
Nice.
That's also a red akah.
There we go.
Nice.
All right.
Don't worry, Madeline.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
You know, I need to buy.
I have enough money, right?
Actually, no.
I should save up for a barista.
I should.
I'm gonna save up for a barista, so I don't have to do this
anymore.
Can I get a...
Never mind.
Thank you for the super chat.
But thank you.
Okay, we gotta fill this up.
No, we have enough coffee beans still.
I mean, I guess we...
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Okay, and then we fill that up.
guys i know we're missing something i remember why this
feels off right now um but first off we got give this to her
yeah what the fuck she took the entire tray with her oh a
customer wrote a review how do i look at my reviews your
shop we only operate during the fall wait my shop's closed
wait my shop's cut how did you get in here wait my shop what
how did she how did she she get in here my shop was closed
how did she how did she get in here guys i'm sorry ma'am
it's illegal for you to be here like it's it's illegal why
are you why are you here okay i guess i have to take her
order all right is it double what was your order that's a 60
right my god how do i already that is a 60 okay all right
boom all right uh okay we got oh these coffees on a whole
other level fake review oh wait that's not what i meant you
should do
all right nice all right oh i should buy the coffee beans uh
we need coffee beans standard I want the cheapest kind is
there a way to buy cheaper coffee we have they're all the
same types of coffee though they're all so expensive uh
we'll just get we'll just get the regular 25 we'll just get
that all right that should be oh we should fill this up
again fill it up you'll never notice uh I can't watch her be
stressed.
It's just making me stressed.
I'm just giving PTSD to people.
Me when I spread misinformation online.
Doctor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, here you go, Madeline.
Wait.
Oh, wait, did I not...
Where did I...
Wait, where did my cup go?
Did I just pour her into another shot glass?
Did I never make you a cup?
I thought I wrote you...
What was your name?
I forgot to give you a name.
There you go.
You get a real name.
All right.
I poured it into another shot glass.
Great streamer.
Whoa, watch again.
Sheila, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't know.
Oh my gosh, she's so happy.
Okay, I'm almost there.
I'm almost at.
Okay, that should be closed now.
All right, now I have the shop to myself.
Okay, let me see.
What do I need?
do to my shop i have an 87 excellence these coffees are a
whole new level this place rocks best coffee in town look at
that everybody loves my coffee chat everybody loves it i
should sell cookies i should do i have a license to sell
like cookies well we'll find out soon all right let's see
what else can i make the expresso machine a100 it can make
expresso faster okay i don't need that I'll be fine.
Those are...
They're not bots.
They're just as real as you guys.
They're just as real.
Why are they all locked?
Please.
I spent my dragon's tuition funds to open my dream store.
My dream coffee shop.
Okay, Sapphire.
We're almost there.
Wait, we're level two.
Cafe upgrade.
I can have bodyguard.
Am I going to get robbed?
Am I...
Like, what?
Like, am I gonna get robbed?
Like, all right.
How do I...
First, you unlock your cafe to level two.
What guarantees a level two?
Why would I need parking space?
Why would I need security?
Why...
I'm so confused.
Oh, my God.
$100 a day?
What the fuck?
I don't even get paid a hundred dollars a day.
Wait.
Okay.
All right, Liam.
You gotta pay your college to it.
What the fuck?
Oh, Liam's fell on hard times.
Oh my god.
Poor Liam.
Okay, let me clean this.
Then clean this.
And pick up my garbage.
bag and wait my cafe is starting to get dirty where's the
where's the trash where's the trash where's the trash where
do i put the trash can i just put the trash here i'm just
gonna put it here this doesn't count right this counts as my
cafe there's no way that counts it's not even all my
property anymore who's gonna be at the back oh it's over
here who's gonna be at the back side of my property like i
don't wait it didn't even matter i could have literally just
thrown what the what happened what happened to my store leon
did you do this okay um all right let's see we gotta oh my
god leon i gotta sweep we gotta sweep it we gotta sweep leon
i know like the financial crisis was like I know like people
are having a hard time Liam and I know that like your work
doing this for your family Liam please I need you please you
should have more than one job sweep sweep sweep sweep please
sweep sweep sweep okay what time at 8 a.m.
okay Liam do you know how to do you know how to make coffee
Liam do you know how to make coffee he gets paid a hundred
dollars a day you cannot say you cannot say that Liam does
not know does not get paid enough Liam gets paid plenty of
money a hundred dollars a day
all right let's see I'm gonna put this supply here my stocks
are update.
That doesn't even include tips.
I'm running better than like 80% of like American restaurant
owners because 80% of them operate on tips alone and pay
like fairly minimum wage.
That doesn't even include the tips.
Who tips baristas?
I tip baristas because I'm a decent person.
I took 15%.
I'm an actual decent person.
Okay.
I think I know why I'm like really stressed out.
I need some coffee.
I need some coffee music.
I need coffee shop music.
Okay.
Coffee shop.
Copyright.
free music okay now I know why I'm like extra stressed out
there we go there we go can you guys hear this you guys hear
it alright alright how about coffee and ambient I need like
ambient noise so I feel like I feel like I'm actually in the
coffee shop I need it
Oh my god.
Alright.
There we go, guys.
Give me a sec.
There we go.
Guys, can you hear this?
Alright.
Oh my god, the longer he's...
I need to go to bed.
I need to...
I need to be more immersed, guys.
Alright, save.
Okay.
I'll up it up a little bit too.
um up it up a little bit there you go just so we feel like
we're there all right let's see i need to interact with bed
bed let me it's i need to be up at eight okay let's see uh
four hours all right sleep all right all right all right
Liam are you ready for another day of hard work Liam in one
day I could finally afford an employee in one day isn't that
crazy we have no bathrooms here um let's see I'm gonna make
sure that we have Liam do you know how to make coffee we can
only make three types of coffee we can make uh all these
three coffees Liam do you know how to make coffee
all right all right let's see they should arrive any moment
now i'm gonna supervise now i'm a supervisor i after one day
of working i have finally uh decided to be a supervisor oh
flip the sign we're open we're open leon's first day of work
There's I swear to fucking Okay Okay Give me a second
Alright There's one There's Okay Okay
There's one Open cashier But no that's okay Okay What does
Liam do?
What does he do?
I'm literally paying him $100.
Okay.
Let's see.
Liam.
Liam, are you working?
Oh my god, Liam's working.
Wait, Liam's working.
Wait, what was...
Okay, that's three.
Okay.
Um, boom.
Alright.
Okay, don't worry.
Put the music a little bit up Pretty immersiveness There you
go Oh my god oh my god he's actually working He's doing it
Oh shit I should grind off I don't know what he's doing
right now But like I think he's Wait is it empty Wait
where's my Do I not have more?
Oh okay there you go Place There you go Alright and then
Fill it up He's doing it He's doing it He hired another
barista, though.
Okay, 60, and then pick up, and then pick up.
Grind, grind, grind, grind, grind.
Oh, my God.
I can make so much money now.
I can have two at once.
Oh, I need to name you.
What's your name?
Your name?
Andre.
Oh, shit.
Uh, uh, Andre.
There we go.
Nice.
And I'll put that here.
No, that doesn't have anything in it.
Please.
I'm so, please.
Okay, and then I fill it up.
I'll fill.
Please, Andre, just stay with me.
I just need to make 30 more.
Please, Andre.
Please, please don't leave, Andre.
Okay.
Oh, and then I throw this away.
Andre, please.
I'm doing my best, Andre.
Okay, and then I fill it up.
Fill, fill, fill, fill, fill, fill.
And then put it in.
And then math.
Andre, we're almost done, Andre.
Please.
We just...
We just need...
Andre, please, please just wait a little bit longer, Andre.
Oh, I need a grind for coffee beans.
I forgot.
Okay, coffee beans.
Fill the coffee beans.
Okay.
Grind, grind, grind, grind.
Andre, I'm almost...
I unlocked...
What the fuck?
I unlocked what?
What did I unlock?
Okay, Andre, please.
Wait, is...
Is it just only two?
Sorry.
Yay!
I did it in advance.
Okay.
Oh, I have an idea.
I'll just leave all these shots here.
So that...
So I have them in advance.
Okay.
That's just one.
And then...
I need...
No!
What the...
Okay.
Knock stand.
Knock box.
and then I already grind that up so then I just need to pour
it 30 in there oh and then I'll put it in and then BAM
what's your name Chris okay Chris don't worry Chris I got
you there you go that's Chris in my language all right I
need I need another staff I need another staff member why
can't I have two staff members why do I?
Why?
What do you mean I have to upgrade my shop store again?
What do you mean?
I don't what do we have to upgrade it again?
Oh, what if I have another shelf?
Um, okay.
Uh, oh, there's so many people.
Um, okay, what if I, what, what if I hire?
Am I level three?
Am I, I'm not, am I like level
is it we're not in the red we have four hundred dollars uh
okay and then we fill it up uh we fill it up right here
don't worry chris i got you and bam chris is happy okay i'm
gonna i need i need upgrade my cafe i don't okay what does
the parking do i don't have money but like i could upgrade
warehouse does this this is upgrade my cafe this is my do i
have enough to hire no mine still not level three i bought
what do you want You want two orders?
Expresso.
What is the expresso?
Oh, that's just 30.
Okay.
Oh, I don't have cups.
I don't...
Okay.
Ordered some cups.
And please, please wait.
I don't have cups.
Okay.
No.
I'm like.
cafe is starting to get dirty no it's okay
okay we need to throw this away okay and then we gotta put
this up wait what do you mean it's empty what what do you
mean did i oh is this already filled this is already filled
oh I get it where's the delivery guy don't have cops I'm
sorry I I don't have cops I I'm sorry I don't we need cops
where's Amazon where's Amazon I just
Guys, I need cubs.
I don't have any cubs.
Um, I did.
I did.
I ordered cubs.
Where's the cubs?
I'm a mess.
I'll order more.
Amazon.
Amazon, where are you?
We can't.
We can't do anything.
Oh, I should clean.
I should I should bring out my broom.
How did this place got dirty too?
Okay, um Hey clean clean clean sweep sweep sweep sweep
Oh, no I
have cups I have cups Oh Okay You can do your order now Okay
Okay, um, um, oh, there, and then, um, and then, Phil, this
is 30, right?
This is, this is the mini, um, and then the, whoa, this is
two, right?
Okay, this is two, okay, okay, shock glass, shock glass,
boom, please wait.
Please wait, sir.
Sir, please.
I got cups.
You are back!
You are...
Oh, wait.
Oh, you are a different guy.
Sorry.
I thought you reminded me of something.
Oh.
Tell you friends.
There you go.
All right.
Nice.
Here you go.
Okay.
Guys, it's a coffee shop music.
Are you guys feeling calm from the coffee shop music, guys?
Guys, are you guys, or are you guys feeling calm from the
coffee shop music?
Is it calming you?
No, not at all.
Wait, was that not coffee?
Is that water?
Did I?
No!
Is this not coffee in here?
What's in here?!
What's in here?
Please wait a little bit, sir!
I accidentally put...
I accidentally put nothing in the filter!
Please!
I did it!
It bugged out!
My coffee shop bugged out!
Yeah, I'll put up the sound a little bit.
I'll put it up a little bit more.
Let me know if you're feeling extra immersive.
Guys, please.
It's almost there, sir.
It's almost there.
Just wait a little longer.
You're getting the customer anxiety.
Please, please, my dragons.
I used their college tuition, sir.
Please, this is all I have You can't leave a negative review
If you leave a negative review All 750,000 Of my dragons
can't go to college
Okay, we're almost there Alright, let's see Okay, nice We
gotta fill it up Alright Please don't leave Please, we're
almost, I'm done yay I did it yay three stars you can't say
best coffee in town and give me three stars okay I'm calm
wait I got new I got new uh I got some more cups guys I got
this chance I'm having more flashbacks um I need I need a
best I need to start investing.
Okay, hello, what do you want?
Okay, that's 60.
I just, I just grinded this out, so we should be good.
All right, and then fill it up.
You know, it's okay.
Everything, they don't need to be happy.
They're here for coffee.
Oh, there we go.
What's your name, sir?
Casey.
Okay, Casey.
Okay.
Send.
Help.
All right.
Let's see.
Where did it go?
Okay.
We're just going to put that just in case if somebody needs
water.
They don't need happiness.
They're here for coffee.
That's enough happiness for them.
That's enough happiness.
What time is it?
It's only 6 p.m.
What do you mean it?
I feel like I've been working for five hours.
already like okay all right all right and then we got
grinder here and we're almost there all right we're working
so hard okay pick up all right fill fill it up okay let's
keep this we only have three reps apiece guys we we've only
three recipes that's like the worst part we've only unlocked
three recipes but i feel like i feel like it's already three
too many it feels like there's it feels way too many okay
we're gonna get we're getting an actual coffee grinder and
then and then we're gonna get um okay we don't you don't
need milk okay we don't need any of that and we don't need
this so we're gonna get What's the...
It consists of a filling chamber.
It's a machine fills the...
Thanks to the filter.
Wait, what?
Why would we need a filter machine?
Okay, we're gonna grab...
The espresso.
Okay, we're broke.
But it's okay.
What do you want?
You want...
Okay, two.
Wait, I just got enough for that.
Okay.
And then we put it here.
And then we fill it up.
We fill it up.
Guys, we can finally upgrade!
um put it here and then poop guys we can finally afford an
upgrade all right danny i'm feeling a little i'm a little
confident here yeah this is how i feel right now i think we
can do this guys i think guys i think i think we're like
actual coffee shop owners now i'm not stressed anymore i i
think i've got the hang hang of this now all right fill fill
fill oh oh no i'm out of coffee um um oh i haven't paid rent
at all oh okay i just oh it's just ten dollars oh my god
thank god rent is just ten dollars all right we'll buy some
you know we'll buy two i feel a little adventurous uh oh no
is this at 60 yet oh when is the delivery truck why does the
delivery take two minutes oh my coffee shop's a mess Um,
that's okay.
I feel great.
I still feel great.
I still feel great, guys.
Everything's a-okay.
Yay!
I still- I still feel great.
Everything is still okay.
Um, um, okay.
And then now it's closing time.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
Let's start cleaning let's start cleaning the shop a little
bit we need a we need to clean the shop now it's time to
clean and then sweep sweep sweep sweep sweep you have to pay
you do you not get automatically paid how are you why do i
have 79 the blessed is this the best place i've ever seen no
I don't think I don't I think he's like automatically paid
for right uh why would I need parking I feel like I don't
need any of that all right that's fine it's okay my order is
here now uh all right let's see this is the electric grinder
um one for making coffee is the grinder fill okay nice now
now I can do it electrically all right that's good that is
good I don't have to worry about that anymore.
And I think I ordered more cups.
I'm pretty sure.
I think we have more cups.
Yeah, it auto pays.
Thank God.
Okay, I don't have to worry about paying him.
I gotta remember to place coffee.
We gotta restock on the coffee.
I'm just waiting.
All right, thank you.
Thank you, Amazon.
All right, and then we place it here.
And then place all.
Alright, nice.
We only allow one order of coffee.
Okay, I need a kettle?
Do I...
I don't know if I want a kettle right about now.
I don't know.
I don't have an express though.
Oh, this is an express though machine.
And then...
Oh, I can upgrade skills.
Customer greatly increases a more...
Oh, I don't want...
Please don't come to my store.
Please...
guys it's okay you don't have to come to my store more i
have enough customers i i have
guys guys it's okay i like i would like more tips though i
oh unlock tip box yay all right decorations um
um is that everything oh i need to fill more coffee okay i'm
gonna like pre-fill coffee i'm gonna pre-fill this here and
then filled this here oh it's 150.
wait that's a lot wait that's so many oh my god wait i can
do so many things with 150.
wait i don't have to grind coffee anymore oh my god i don't
have to grind coffee anymore how do i how do i do this Do I
just turn it on?
Oh my god.
I don't have to be a caveman anymore.
Okay, and then...
We're going to empty this up.
And fill it up.
Oh, I can only still only fill 30, though.
I... Oh my god, technology.
Oh my god, technology.
Okay, uh, we're going to...
You know what?
I'm going to pre-make.
I'm going to pre-make shots.
Oh my... I figured this out, guys.
guys i figured this out we pre-make the shots now so like we
don't have to worry we don't have to worry about oh i need
to buy more cups okay cups uh let's buy more minis because
like i don't want you guys to order anything more like you
guys already we already have too many things no it's okay
they won't know it doesn't tell temperature they won't know
They won't be able to tell
I guess I'll be like, please, if you're going to cut
corners, wait till day three I was like, some music, is the
coffee shop music good enough now?
All right, I swear, okay, we're going to experiment, okay?
In 94, wait, it's going down.
Wait, no.
Does anyone want cold coffee?
Does anyone...
I need to be able to afford...
Okay, we need seven hours.
I need to afford a microwave so I can microwave the coffee.
We'll be able to...
able to microwave the coffee later um oh no how far is it oh
it's so it's so warm it's so warm i knew it i knew oh my god
oh my god we did it it's so warm it's so warm okay i got it
90 fahrenheit coffee so don't know it's still warm it's
still warm All right.
And I'll fill it up.
I'll fill it up.
It's so warm.
It's still there.
It's so ready.
We're so ready.
Come in, please.
Somebody.
Somebody come in.
Right now.
Wait, is that Celsius?
It was seven.
There's no way.
It's seven.
Okay, what do you want?
Oh.
60 wait no wait isn't isn't like mini wait what did you want
espresso no you ordered the one thing i don't have okay oh
my god it was a 30 it was a 30 but that's okay that's okay
it's okay the next customer the next customer is gonna order
one it's still fine we're still fine We're so healthy.
What's your name?
Wait, you're Tom.
Okay, you're Tommy.
Uh, hot coffee.
There you go.
And then I'll put that here.
And then I don't need to grind anything anymore, so we're
fine.
Um, where's my Amazon?
Okay, we need more cups.
We need more cups, though.
We need, we need more cups.
Alright.
Bam!
I think we're gonna, we need to make more.
We need to make more money.
so we can buy a better coffee machine.
So we can make more coffee.
Oh, no, it's at 63.
Oh, please.
Is it done yet?
Oh, it's done.
Okay.
Which one's the right one?
This one right here.
All right.
Wait, I have two customers.
I have two customers.
Why do I have two customers?
You also want an... Why do you all want an espresso?
I don't understand.
How do you all want expressos?
all right right right here oh no my coffee's not getting hot
anymore okay oh my gosh please please it's at 56 degrees
celsius now no Liam what do I do Liam my reviews are going
down not anymore
the best barista town don't keep please you have to spend
your money and actually improving your store not buying fake
reviews you can't stop me all right here you go uh all right
what's okay um i got this is how i feel Do you want?
What do you want?
You also want an expresso.
Why do you all, you guys want expressos?
I don't understand.
Why do you all want expressos?
Alright.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Um.
We should have more shot glasses.
We have unlimited shot glasses so we're fine.
Alright.
I'm 200.
Let's see.
Okay, and then we gotta pick your... What's your name?
Neil?
This is how I feel.
Neil, please.
This is how I feel, Neil.
I don't want you to be sad.
Please.
I just want somebody to order.
And order a copy.
Please.
It's at 35 Celsius.
it is all right 319 how much do i need to like buy this
fancy espresso i need like 500 for the fancy espresso oh but
i could get like a coffee filter and open new recipes oh
wait isn't that oh i got one it's okay one of them might not
be as good anymore but that's okay uh then we're gonna pick
that up and put that here.
I do not get paid to smile.
That's extra.
Um, extra hot coffee.
Okay.
Coffee.
Oh, wait, I can, like, rotate it.
Now I'm angry, sad.
if you want me to smile that's extra that's that's extra oh
my god please why can't this machine be faster okay guys if
i was happy i would not be a brewster right now
please okay let's see we fill it up all right this is fine
this is fine we're making money we're making good progress
this is absolutely fine yeah he's happy okay all right my
reviews are back to 80 best place i've ever seen when you
want okay that's two how much more okay i need to put more
coffee in here give me a sec ma'am i need to put more coffee
in the in this grinder it's okay we ordered two so we should
have enough nice okay that's fine we're fine everything's
fine guys i know like we haven't made any like actual profit
and we're still investing in the store but that's okay it's
a long game here um and then um we gotta put this away and
then put this in and put that in here and i still have
plenty of shot glasses guys go oh wait i should pour the
rest of this coffee in here too uh all right all right
that's fine okay what's your name eva get in oh what the
fuck that's your twin wait what the fuck triplets wait
they're all the wait what wait okay there's a glitch in the
matrix there it is
I think there's a glitch in the matrix, guys.
All right.
It's okay.
One of the triplets is having a good time.
One of the triplets got their order.
Why do you line up on my side?
We have a barista.
All right.
Okay.
Wait.
Did you...
wait whose coffee is this is your coffee wait then whose
coffee is this wait i'm so why do i have we got two why do i
have two cups i don't know i don't know why i have two cups
okay that's that's a lot of shots okay and then we put that
in here and then we fill this up one but like when did I
when did I have a second a second one when did that cast my
brain's breaking when did that happen I don't remember okay
we're gonna get the expensive one we can afford the the
expensive espresso machine um we need the expensive this is
faster uh what does he want he also wants an express So, and
this is a triplo, so, like, I need two shot glasses.
Um, I'm more shot glasses in here.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
Everything.
Wait, why is he angry?
Why are you angry?
What?
What did I do?
Why?
I don't understand.
Why was he angry?
Like, he didn't want to.
wait we have two lines okay sir please don't be angry i'm
just an anime girl
sir please please don't be angry this anime girl's gonna cry
all right let's see we need okay and then we got person too
all right please please Nathan please I'm trying my best
Nathan I'm please don't be angry at me please I'm gonna cry
all right all right your cafe is starting to get dirty what
do you want me to do I'm just one person.
It's just me and Liam.
Like, if you don't like it, dear, just leave.
Just leave my cafe.
I already had too many customers.
I have too many customers.
I don't need all of you here.
Okay.
We got this.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Did I pour everything in?
Okay.
I think I did.
Oh, thank God.
All right, what do you want?
You want a espresso.
Okay, the espresso is easy.
Express is easy.
Okay.
All right, we gotta fill it up.
We gotta fill it up.
What did you say?
40, 50, 60.
Oh my God, there's still four more hours of work.
There's still, okay, that's okay.
What did you want?
That's one, one.
Okay, boom.
Oh, our other one is here.
It's okay, we have...
We have, we have the better coffee machine!
Okay, we're gonna put the better coffee machine here.
Alright, nice.
And then we're gonna put that here.
And then, um, are you, oh shit.
What's your name, sir?
Nathan, don't worry, Nathan.
Asshole.
Oh, there we go.
That's you.
That's fucking right, Nathan.
I called you out.
You made me want to cry.
That's fucking right.
I hope you know what you are.
Alright, Express.
I want to use my new machine.
Okay, how do I use my new machine?
Wait, it's still 30?
Wait, do I have no more?
Wait, what?
Is there no more in there?
Is that it?
Is that actually it?
wait how do i how do i put this on what the fuck what did
you do liam
i'm so confused wait they're not grind oh i didn't grind it
yet okay fill it and i'll fill the rest of this here and
then um how do i put it on
this on oh there it is wait where's my other wait what
happens to my other grinder wait where did my electric
grinder go did it glitch out wait my electric grinder is
gone
my electric grinding no oh my god oh oh it's in my
inventory.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna freak out.
I was actually not to do this again.
It refunded my car.
Liam, you fucker!
No!
Liam!
Is there... Oh, no.
I don't have enough beans.
Do I have enough beans?
Oh, I do.
Oh, my God.
Liam's sabotage.
I can do this again!
Okay.
Guys, guys, please.
I'm sorry.
I...
Oh, no.
My reviews.
Okay.
I need more coffee.
No, I will get through you.
Um, please give up.
Why are you crying?
I'm going to be crying first before you.
Like...
Like, why are you crying?
Is it... Does it finish grinding?
Is it done?
Oh, I think it's done.
Okay.
Okay, and then we're full of this.
I think that's 30 at the...
that point no do i not have enough do i do i not have enough
in there wait do i not have enough what happened okay um and
then what did you want you wanted triplo oh um i'm sorry i'm
please leo please leave me alone leo Liam!
Leave me alone!
What are you?
Stop, Liam!
There's nothing in there!
Why is there nothing in there?
Why is there?
Why is it water?
Is there anything?
What?
Why?
Why is it water?
I thought I put... Oh my god, I thought it...
I'm sorry, please, sir.
I don't have coffee.
I ran out of coffee.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Alright.
Please, if you can wait 25 more seconds.
Please.
Things are getting really out of hand.
If you can wait 25 more seconds, please.
Wait, the other garbage bag is gone.
Oh, it works.
We just leave it outside.
please please sir let me do you want to talk sir like if we
talk then like things can be fine yeah gargoyle arrived oh
my god we have more coffee we have more coffee oh that's so
good we have we actually we actually have more coffee oh all
right um and then we gotta place all our coffee here place
all and then um um where's our grinder okay we fill our
grinder up please sir just wait Just wait a little bit
longer.
Please don't leave.
Sir, please.
Please just wait like five more minutes, sir.
I'm doing my best.
I'm doing my absolute best right now.
Okay, and then...
Then we're going to put these here.
And I think it's done filling.
Okay, and then we're going to fill it up here.
and I'm just gonna keep blending it I think that worked and
and grind grind grind and it was triplo right triplo okay oh
I think I'm more shot glasses here and here we go boom we're
making coffee please just stay with us for for a little
longer let's just stay with us a little longer i'm gonna
write your name what's your name herman herman well that's
your name
all right all right there you go um is that is it filled
okay we fill this up we fill this up herman please stay with
me stay with me a little longer how is this faster this is
not faster at all please how is this faster herman herman is
still here Hermit's still with us.
Hermit's still with us.
Thank you, Hermit.
No!
Happy customer.
All right.
Sweep, sweep, sweep, sweep.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Okay.
And then...
Garbage.
Boop.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Guys, I think opening a copy shop was a mistake.
I think...
Guys, I don't think this was the right idea.
Let me clean this first before.
Okay, I'm cleaning this, and I'm going to put you here.
and then and then i cleaned i cleaned this and all the
containers full already okay i need a i need to pick it up
throw it in and and then clean clean okay and then i need to
guys guys i don't think anybody anyone of us are going back
to college i don't And I need a filter machine.
I need to buy that.
And I'm going to...
I bought a filter.
So now we have more recipes.
We got filtered coffee.
Made by brewing hot water over coffee grounds and letting
the resulting drip through a filter.
How do you do that?
How do you...
that.
What does that mean?
Guys, I want to upgrade.
I want to get a bathroom.
Guys, I think my plan is perfect.
I'm going to have you guys.
None of you guys are getting So you're forced to work here
in my coffee shop until we pay things off.
Until I don't.
Oh my god, I can increase the cargo price.
And then, let's see, more customers will leave positive
reviews.
Oh my god, I can buy more bots to leave positive reviews on
my store.
Wait, that sounds great.
Let's see.
what's a thousand connector your cafe can work one
additional no that is okay i already work too much here i
that's okay i think i work more than enough in this cafe i'm
just gonna sit here to wait for our shop to give me more
stuff oh my god now now i know why now now i know why now i
know why oh my god oh now i know why people were like this
game is really stressful now i understand i laughed about it
but oh my god why did i laugh about it Okay, I want most
important materials of my coffee shop.
Alright, how do I do this?
Coffee grind, coffee filter paper.
What?
Do I just pour?
I'm gonna pour this.
I'll pour that.
And then pour.
poor why poor oh filter paper filter paper oh filter paper
I'm so confused no I need it I think my guy needs to sleep
okay wait i need to pour more beans though fill oh because
it's already crushed all right um all right guys we gotta no
we don't have material okay we're gonna sleep a little bit
we're gonna sleep until six so then we have time to figure
this out all right save save um and then gonna sleep two
hours two hours all right that should be enough has our
stuff oh our stuff has arrived nice all right oh my gosh
it's only day three it's only we should not have had three
wi-fi we shouldn't free free wi-fi was a mistake um where
did the filter paper go filter paper paper okay and then
coffee and then
bean no bean don't go inside bean oh oh oh oh oh oh bean
yes i figured it out guys i figured it out guys i figured
out where the beans go i figured out where the beans go oh
my god we're learning how to make coffee okay grind we have
to watch this grind now we still have lots of time all right
language because because people are so really hard
Wait, do I need water?
Do I need water in the coffee mug?
Or is that good to go?
Are we good to go?
Do I need water?
Oh my god, okay.
How do I fill it up?
Do I fill up with shock glasses?
No?
How do I...
How do you fill up water?
Water go where?
Water?
water um water why is water not going what water please why
is why can't i fill it up water a machine?
Water?
Water machine?
What?
Um.
Maybe if I um maybe Oh.
Water here?
No?
Read the recipe.
Filter coffee is made by pouring hot water over coffee
grounds and letting the resulting brew drip through what?
I need a kettle!
You need a kettle?
Are you fucking?
Okay, you can feel it while you're using it.
It has a large, most coffee you need this machine.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you?
Okay.
All right, I need a kettle.
It didn't tell me I need a kettle when we had the recipe.
As no one comes to a coffee shop expecting it to be clean.
That's all I'm going to say.
Have you never...
No, all I drink is canned coffee.
Guys, don't make me bring this right now.
I swear to God If I hear I'm here one more critique on my
store I swear to God Nathan I swear to fucking God I'll do
it I'll fucking do it Espresso Okay Alright let's see We
need to Alright We gotta grab that here And then poop And
then we gotta grab that here and this here bam alright and
then what's your name again?
What's your name?
Nathan okay tip me please
or I'll cry
oh yeah you had two orders give me a sec
all right there you go two orders i think that one's done
okay
and then that's your order and then this is also your order
right here that pour in the car okay i thought i poured it
into another shot glass because i've done that before All
right, what do you want?
You want an espresso.
Oh, an espresso.
That's easy to do.
Oh, I guess we're an easier way for this.
An espresso.
All right.
Don't worry.
I got you.
It would be nice addition to my coffee's honor, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I should have a kettle now.
I have a kettle.
Guys, I got a kettle.
How do I do this?
Okay.
the water.
Okay, that seems easy.
Alright, let's fill this with 350 right off the bat.
You forgot my... Nathan!
Nathan, leave.
Leave the store.
You'll come back anyway, because I'm the closest coffee shop
to your house.
I could treat you like this, because you're not gonna walk
another block for your coffee.
You know you need the store more than the store needs you.
All right, let's see, let's pour her.
All right, here you go.
And then we're going to put this on the stove.
And then, poof.
All right, what do you want?
Why are you on my line?
We don't have medium.
There's medium coffee cups now.
We have other sizes.
No, we have other sizes.
Why are you crying?
Oh, because you don't have much to live and you're wasting
majority of your remaining lifespan here waiting for your
fucking coffee?
Good!
Wait, does it have beans?
Does it have any?
Yeah, it does.
Okay, it does have beans.
Mini-Expresso.
Yay!
Okay.
Let's see.
Here we go.
And then...
We gotta pick it up.
Wait, I thought they're not.
Is it ready?
Container?
Oh, containers full.
Okay, let's pick that up.
And then we'll put that here.
And we have $95.
What do I spend?
Oh, I spent it on... Oh, I remember.
I spent it on...
More cups.
Only I'm allowed... Exactly.
Only I'm allowed to cry in my coffee shop.
better than me just because you're here using my services
okay um what's your name lola lola hello lola this is the
one time you i gave a normal name on this on this coffee cup
all right all right here you go let's all right all right
lola oh hello granny you want filtered coffee i don't even
have a small oh my gosh it's 30 more seconds um um okay
we're gonna um wait what does she want americano i have an
americano how the do you make an americano espresso and
water oh okay so you just want watered coffee okay oh my god
i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't have amazon's coming okay thank
god okay amazon's here all right let's see all right i have
cups now um small coffee okay what do you how do i small
filter how do i make filter coffee again i how do i how do i
make filter coffee um filter coffee 236 millimeters oh no
that's not what i want all right let's see filter your
coffee um lid um is this is hot enough still not hot enough
wait why is the water going down oh it's evaporating it's
How do I...
How do I put water inside?
How do I feel it?
Is that...
How do I...
How do I feel it?
How do I feel...
Feel the water?
How do I...
Is it filling?
Is it doing anything?
Is it...
Is your coffee going in there?
I can't tell It's just Steve I can't tell It's just Oh
coffee's going in Coffee's going in Oh my god it's working
Okay Okay what do you want Americano Americano you need At
least Liam's picking up the slack Okay Americ...
americano um um can i take it off of okay what size what
size americano big why do you need a big americano um 120
express 120 espresso just leave just leave my store
what what how much small filtered coffee small 354 i don't
do i have 354 i i'm fucking leave
that's my no
It's okay, I'll buy another review.
It's okay, it's okay guys, I bought another review to
balance things out.
It's okay, it's okay guys.
I bought another review so it's like it never happened.
it's like it never happened guys they beat me five stars
thanks cats are balancing it out wait what is it a mini oh
thank god it's a mini thank god anytime i see a mini i'm
like oh thank you oh thank you Please move!
I can't see!
I can't see, Liam!
What's your name?
Oh, it's Lola, you came back!
Lola!
Lola, you came back, Lola!
Alright.
Lola!
Lola is my best customer.
I think Lola's the best one so far.
She likes being mistreated.
He's working.
Leave him alone.
your cafe starting to dirty it's been like it's 84 that's
like that's at least passable by like by like the safety
inspector as long as the safety inspector does not complain
i do not need to clean my cafe i do not need to clean
anything all right let's see okay that's good oh my god What
do you want?
Okay, Lola.
What do you want?
You want a...
Oh my god.
You left a cigarette box in my...
Oh, please.
How much do I need to do to upgrade?
I need 200 more.
As soon as I get $200, I can...
I can have another barista, I think.
I think so.
Is that enough of an upgrade?
How much is this security?
2,500.
Why would I need more security?
Like, why would I need more?
I don't understand.
okay uh and then we fill it up when we need grind some more
coffee uh all right grind some coffee and then fill it up
fill it up all right guys give me a sec i like i know i said
why i need more security because i feel like i feel like
like i haven't been robbed yet oh my god i'm gonna Why would
you want to rob this place?
I don't even have a working bathroom.
Like, what is there to rob?
I don't even have working toilets.
I just have expensive overpriced coffee.
This is worse than Supermarket Simulator.
I can't say it.
This is so much worse.
Okay.
Oh my god.
You unlocked the bathroom.
through if I need to go.
Alright, let's see.
I'm going to put this here.
And then we're going to grab a new shot glass.
Oh my god, this isn't even a nice coffee.
I literally bought the beans from Walmart.
Why are you all still here?
Who keeps leaving good reviews?
I just wanted to be like an indie coffee shop.
Why is there three of you now?
Who Who keeps recommending my coffee shop?
It's supposed to be like indie, indie.
We're supposed to be hipster.
All right, let's see.
Oh, no.
Oh, I need...
Okay, I need to grab...
Where am I?
16?
Not yet.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Who keeps...
Who keeps recommending us?
What's your name?
um uh wait did you want mini mini okay uh leave okay nice
all right and then there's my other shock glass here you go
all right there you go all right poor word of mouth who
keeps recommending stop stop word of mouthing this coffee
shop Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Gotta see an actor.
I pretend to get beat.
A really interesting idea of a coffee shop.
Mini Express.
So that was one, right?
That's one.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Pue.
And then pour this in.
This coffee shop was good before it became popular.
Thank you for the super chat.
Many.
Thank you.
Your calf.
Oh, I don't have I don't have a shot glass in here.
Okay Guys, when do I get to unlock other please please I
just want to I want to unlock the please please calm down
everybody Please calm down I'm not even now Liam where did
Liam go Liam?
Why are you working faster Liam?
Oh, um, we're doing too well Please leave more negative
reviews guys, please leave more We have too many people in
the shop Leave negative reviews, don't come back Please, oh
thank god, thank god they hurt me
Oh thank god, leave Okay, oh thank god, thank god they're
actually leaving Oh my god Okay, all right.
Okay, last customer of the day.
Yay.
I missed when they gave me $90 per coffee.
Oh, they're ordering the cheapest coffee.
That's why.
What the fuck?
They're so cheap.
Oh, I need a clean.
Clean, clean, clean.
Clean, clean.
clean clean clean sweep sweep okay um okay and then we gotta
pick up the cigarette boxes and the cigarettes who keeps
smoking in my coffee shop it literally says no smoking who's
smuggling smokes in my coffee shop i know the trash cans
over here but i've been trying to say i can collect trash
bags up back here nobody can tell anyway nobody can tell
Liam, are you smoking in my coffee shop?
What are you stressed out about?
I'm the one...
Oh my god, he has to do two orders.
Okay, let's see.
What are you stressed out about, Liam?
You had less customers to deal with than me!
Do I have anything coffee in here?
Wait, what?
Did it not throw away the coffee?
it's the containers full okay all right the trash bags and
then and then we put that in and then we fill it up
gives Liam a no nobody deserves break in this coffee shop
none of us deserves it if i'm gonna be unhappy my workers
Everybody has to be unhappy.
Nobody can feel joy in this coffee shop.
That's just the way it is.
That's the stuff.
Why are you still working, Liam?
Where's the coffee?
The person's very busy, please leave her a lot.
I can't thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Liam!
Where the fuck is this guy's coffee?
Where is this guy's coffee?
Liam!
Where's the coffee, Liam!
He only gets $100 a day And he has three kids with three
different ladies That he even smoked Thank you with a super
chat Deadpool thank you Thank you Leo What the man Morgan's
crying How hard is it to get a fucking Americano
I'm starting to think that Doki isn't cut out to be a
barista all right thank you for the zoom chat they get the
way talking about i'm a great barista oh dear we're gonna
get toilet soon
leah please it's almost midnight leah we closed three hours
ago how are you stop fucking leaving.
Fuck this shit.
I'm gonna fucking go to bed.
I gotta go to bed.
I am thinking with a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm only on day four.
How have I played this game for two hours already?
There's no fucking way.
I play this game for two hours.
Holy shit.
I feel like I oh my god it did not feel like two hours oh my
god okay all right um what do we need already okay i put
coffee grounds already over here and then all right we need
two more hours um we're gonna order more coffee just in case
just in case i feel like order i feel like we definitely
need more let's see we don't need milk yet so we're gonna
need we're gonna need oh i can sell supplies or food wait i
could have done that okay we need toilets first though we
definitely need toilets first we're so close to toilets we
need 200 uh i want to sleep for two more hours so we can
open up johnny thank you the super chat thank you thank you
john don't keep doing overtime on gambling
all right we just need like two hours and then that should
be good all right Liam you live here you don't even get to
sleep you don't get to go home and see your family you live
here until you pay off my debt you need this job more than
you need anything else and you know that you're here for a
fucking ever let's Okay, we should be able to open.
You're never going to see your family again until I pay off
all the debt I have.
Alright, what does he want?
We want filtered coffee and big Americano.
How much is the filtered again?
Filtered coffee.
Medium, right?
437 filtered.
Wait, is it medium?
Okay, big Americano.
Alright, 28 degrees.
degrees of coffee.
That is fine by me.
Wait, well, how many was it, guys?
Guys, I already forgot.
How many was it?
Guys, how many was it?
Guys, how many was it again?
I read it, but now I forgot.
Guys,
was it 402?
Okay, I'm fucking reading this.
Uh, filtered medium.
400.
Oh, it's full.
Okay, it's full.
all right here we go 470 we just had to fill it all the way
up so we should be good all right 473 that's a medium right
yeah that's a medium guys don't worry we're gonna heat this
up guys i have a plan i have a huge plan guys i didn't even
have to buy a kettle I can't believe you guys told me to buy
a kettle I didn't even need the kettle And the water
originally already came Oh my god Okay we're gonna put this
away So I can put Oh I can't I can't put the I can't fucking
heat up my Oh my gosh okay Calm down
Come down Come down calm down okay okay i'm here big
americano uh-huh 471 and one espresso okay 471 and one
espresso okay um all right and then i'll just put that back
on um where's the big where's big okay big okay big okay
all right let's see and then we're gonna grab this i'm gonna
fill it up we're gonna fill it up
473 it's okay wait it was water oh my god oh my god i'm so
fucking this is why i needed the kettle for oh my god okay
it's okay i i figured it out wait how do i put water in here
What do I?
What do I pour water?
Wait.
Is it normal water?
Oh, normal water.
Wait, tap water?
Okay, that does not sound right.
Wait, wait a minute.
What?
Wait, tap water?
It's...
Okay, we're going to put it all the way here.
473.
Wait, I should put the shot in first.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
He's still here.
Alright, we got that in, and then and then we put water in.
Alright, nice.
And then that should be 473.
I got plus 10 popularity.
Please, why is my cafe still so popular?
I don't... Please.
All right, guys, you're gonna get some nice juicy tap water
coffee.
Oh, no, man.
I don't feel good about using...
Oh, whatever.
Who cares what I feel?
Like, cool.
Wait.
I don't...
I don't think this is correct.
Oh, that's alright.
That'll be fine.
He's still happy.
It's a freezing Who asked you Oh I can buy a toilet I just
have a little extra water It's just a little extra Alright
nice Do I have Do I have another barista now?
I have a bathroom guys Oh god Okay Oh Oh, the bills.
You're right.
There you go.
What do you want?
Americano?
Don't worry, man.
Okay, Americano.
I need...
Okay, I don't want to do another coffee here, so I'm just
going to do it here.
Boom.
Okay, that's like...
What is the Americano again?
That was like...
Oh, 120 espresso.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I gave him less coffee, but, like, he was
happy, though.
You know what, that's fine.
I gave him less coffee, but he was still happy, you know?
Like, they don't know.
They're too stupid for that, yeah.
They're too...
They don't know.
It's just...
He was fine.
He didn't notice.
I told you guys Like these people don't know anything about
like regular coffee They don't know anything They can't tell
They order the drink and they're just satisfied No no In the
jack shit Why are you there at the coffee shop?
Alright let's put that at 400 Alright and then Where's my
other Um, oh, that's just water.
Eh.
No!
She knew!
This is not coffee.
I should have put espresso.
God damn, I should have put espresso.
Oh, there's so many people that want so many coffee.
I'm done It's over It's over Get over here I don't have any
It's over me Get out Get out Get out Get out I'm done I'm
done I'm done!
I'm done!
Hey, my popularity increased.
Alright.
Guys.
Being a barista is really hard.
I don't...
I don't want to be a barista anymore.
I know.
I think I think I'm I'm thinking I'm ready to close up my
shop I think Okay I got Hey guys I got I got more coffee
guys Hey Hey my coffee arrived Yay Hey guys I restart
Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god I restocked.
Shane, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Moy, Moy, Kun, for my double espresso caro
macchiato with whipped cream and chocolate sprinkles on top
with a breakfast croissant.
I can give you this.
No, I can't hit Liam.
I can't hit Liam.
Oh.
all right guys it's it's announcement time let me swap over
okay okay
oh my god oh my god i can't i thought you know i thought you
know i don't know i thought simulator would be okay but i
didn't realize i i didn't realize how not okay i was
i was i was i was absolutely not okay Absolutely not okay.
Shout out to all the baristas out there.
Shout out to you guys.
I can't last longer than five days.
Being a barista.
I cannot.
I thought.
I was like, it's just coffee.
How hard can making coffee be?
There's like hundreds of Tim Hortons out there.
How hard can it be?
There's so many like indie coffee shops where all the
hipsters go like surely like it can't be that difficult Oh
my god, I was so wrong.
I had like five orders.
I have five items on my menu.
I haven't even gone to the lattes I haven't gotten to the
milk yet I haven't I haven't even I haven't even gotten to
the milk portion of the recipe Why was this so difficult?
There was just five recipes.
Dark Blade, do not call Tim Hortons coffee, please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
People snub by Tim Hortons over making their own coffee.
That's all I'm saying.
Oh my God.
We were only at the beginning of the game.
was so much it was so much holy shit oh anyway anyway guys
all right whoa i'm really nervous about some of these
announcements but let me stretch before i do it whoa all
right so um this announcement sort of already got leaked out
because i i saw people that were like oh my god is this the
dough is this actually dokey so like some of you guys
already know this announcement because it got leaked out and
then you got like posted somewhere so then people were like
oh my god
so i thought it was really but i couldn't confirm or deny it
until like today so all right there's actually um there's
also one things that um oh my gosh it has been on my goals
list for a very long time um it's been on the goals list for
a long time so um i said like out of uh
um i'm like super super nervous but like i feel you guys
already know with the announcement.
I like how I'm wearing my barista uniform.
Okay, guys, let me take off my barista uniform at my face.
Let me, give me a sec.
I need to take off my uniform first.
If I'm gonna do this announcement, give me a sec.
Okay, let me, alright.
My uniform's off now.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I'm like super I'm super duper nervous But I will show the
graphic first Why I'm like I'm like Yay This is actually one
of my dreams One of my dreams So I'm really really really
excited Okay guys Sorry Sorry I realized I need to move away
a little bit But I'm gonna Let me like move first uh let me
let me move a little bit first guys okay all right for real
now for real for for real now but this this announcement has
been leaked earlier um because some people saw a particular
thing on a pamphlet and it is ta-da i'm going to be at acg
HK um in hong kong um it i've always thought this would
never happen for me um because um for those who don't know
um acghk is the biggest uh convention in hong kong and um
this has been not this has been like my number one
convention that I wanted to do in my career and I always
thought that like it was never possible that I didn't have a
lot of fans to make it possible and I thought I wasn't like
popular enough in Hong Kong to do this because ACG HK is
like basically like the Comic-Con for NA and ACG HK is like
the Comic-Con Kong so so it is a huge honor to be invited um
and this is like one of my dream conventions uh to be
invited to this convention because uh acghk was like my very
first convention as a child like it was the very first
convention I ever went to um and you know I had like a lot
of very happy memories going there like for like a couple of
years um and I spent a lot of money at ACGHK and it's like
um honestly like uh the big one the biggest honors to have
and to be invited um to be invited for this year for it um
and yeah this is like literally my dream convention so I'm
really thankful for them to invite me I'll be at the main
stage yes I will be at the main stage so the main stage
panel it's already the link was that they released the
pamphlet of the schedule and people saw like uh doki's Hong
Kong adventures on there and they were like is that the real
dokey in the pamphlet yes that is me i that was that was me
on the that is me so people couldn't tell couldn't tell if
it was like uh if it was like me or like some other dokey
anyway anyway so i would be at the main stage and um there's
gonna be games a q1 and some yeah some like mini games and a
panel um and it's free to watch basically so for like those
in hong kong um it is free to watch you don't have to pay
any tickets but they are releasing five types of merch uh
including a new hong kong style key visual and details of
that will be announced soon so there's gonna be like five
merch created just for regarding uh regarding this hosting a
uh meeting greet for this session um and basically if you
buy the bundle set of my merch you can join the meeting
greet uh before my main stage panel so uh or like panel mini
games and everything so that is uh so you buy the bundle
merch you basically would be able to do a meeting greet but
there is a max number so it is like first come first sir
when it comes to um when it
and uh oh my gosh i'm just i'm just really really happy
because this is like i said this is like one of my dream
goals to accomplish like i remember in the past when i was
like the one convention that i really really really want to
go was acghk and i honestly i always thought that like i was
just not popular enough in hong kong um to be it but it was
just i was proven wrong i was i was i was rhyme.
My fans always were like, that's not true, Doki.
We want you there.
We want you to meet you.
So I'm really happy.
I'll be speaking Cantonese.
I'll try to be speaking Cantonese.
So I'll try my best.
I'm gonna try my best to speak Cantonese.
And oh my gosh, funny story.
But like, they were like, please don't swear because there's
children.
So I will try not to swear.
I'm gonna try very hard to be PG I'm gonna try so hard to be
PG
I mean this would be the hardest mission ever here and gotta
stay PG for the children for the children Doki um another
thing is that I will be at um not this isn't like The only
appearance that I'll be making in Hong Kong.
I will be at Yusun's concert.
So that would be a week after ACGHK.
And basically it is an independent event in Hong Kong.
Sorry, I have like, I need to remember, like stuff I had to
remember to say about it because there's a lot of details.
And there will be a fan support zone where like fans can
start basically a fan campaign for me and Yusun.
I will be performing with Yusun for this concert.
It's like basically a week after ACGHK.
And we did prepare some secret content there too, not just
the song.
And
I'm just so excited.
I really am.
This is actually like I said, it's a world tour.
It's a world tour.
And we added so many destinations on this real tour uh to be
able to meet you guys meet all the dragoons and everything
and i'm honestly i'm just i i'm just so excited to uh meet
dragons around the world and to be able to announce the hong
kong edition as well um and like you know being able to do a
convention that was basically like my my very first ever
convention that i've ever went to as a child and just and
then being on the main stage now that's that's that's a lot
it's something that you know i never expected at all to
happen in my life so i'm super thankful and i'm just i'm
just really happy and to be able to have this opportunity
with all of you guys um okay this is not the last this is we
have an announcement for so now some of you guys are like so
what is tomorrow's secret stream um okay this is also
another dream that i never thought would be a reality so we
literally like finalized the details for this like this
morning so um i was like That's why I was like, oh, I don't
know if like tomorrow I can even do this secret stream
because like we're still Negotiating details about what I'm
supposed to be doing and everything Um, so we literally
finalized all the details this morning So I can finally
announce it and it's not secret anymore And um, oh my god,
okay, let me I need to get the graphics.
I need to get the graphics in
And you guys are going to be like, oh my god.
You're all going to be like, oh my god.
Basically, drum roll please.
To celebrate Neopets' 25th anniversary.
I will be doing a sponsored stream with Neopets.
um they have announced a new storyline a new plot uh and
storyline uh regarding uh to celebrate its 25th neopets
anniversary and we're gonna be looking through the website
and looking through the new plot line and the new comic
series that's based off the new plot um so i'm super excited
uh i'm really really excited uh to show you showcase it to
you guys it's called the within and oh my gosh I remember
looking through like the the plot like the plots they would
have and like the guy like the little storylines they would
have and everything the lore um and Neopets um the one with
like the the Neopets Atlantis was it Mara I don't know how
to pronounce it because I would always read the names but
the the the Mara Mara Quan or what the Mara I could never
pronounce the name of the land but there was that one and
there was the one with the Altador the Altador's secret
Altadors and then that led to like the the Olympics of
neopets and then there was one with the Daragon kingdom and
then there's the other oh my god there were so many one with
Dr. Sloth oh my gosh but they have a new plot line they have
a new plot line called the void within and it is gonna be
sponsored by Neopets to celebrate their 25th anniversary.
I'm super duper, duper, duper, duper, duper excited to be
able to do this with Neopets as a collaboration, and I hope
to have more feature collabs with them.
Yeah!
It was great working with them on this.
They were like, what's your favorite Neopets?
And I gave them a huge job list, and then we're like, okay,
we'll see what we can do here
Tomorrow's stream gonna be about.
It is a Neopets-centric stream.
And, like I said, it's just as to look.
They asked me to look at the Void Within.
But most likely, I'll also be looking at other stuff too.
I might even go overtime than what they paid me.
Because, like, I love Neopets.
And I can't believe I'm being paid for.
I'm being paid for to play a childhood game.
That I invested, like, a lot, a lot of hours as a kid.
That's crazy to think about.
and like they're paying me to play their website and it's
just insane to think about it's insane to think about and
i'm really thankful too and they sent me like care packages
and everything and it's just a really huge shout out to uh
to neopets team uh uh tnt for for uh organizing all of it
and that's what basically basically what tomorrow's stream
is um so the two announcements Neopet stream tomorrow.
Neopet sponsored stream tomorrow and ACG-HK.
Yeah.
I'm super excited for you.
I can't, oh my gosh.
Little Doki would be so, would be like, what the fuck?
Sorry, I would not say what the fuck during the ACG-HK
thing, but like Little Doki would be like, what the fuck?
It's such a, such a huge honor.
I'm so excited for you guys to see, the merch uh that would
be sold there as well um regarding if there's going to be
online sales for the merch i'll ask my uh ask my management
team um because i actually don't know the answer to that but
if there's i think like i'll see um i'll ask if there's like
um if there's like remaining stock if they can sell it
online as well um i saw the key visual of it it looks really
amazing
But yes, those are the two announcements.
That's basically the two announcements of the day.
I'm really, really, really happy.
And, oh my God, there's...
That's what I'm saying.
Every day I'm just so busy.
I'm just so fucking busy every day.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you all for the support and everything.
appreciate it um
sorry um my mom came in and was like remember to say these
things and i was like i already said it so you're like what
is she doing it i was just like i was like i already i
already said it
um thank you guys um thank you for being here for my journey
to be able to have like just to be able to experience all of
that i never expected to you know be able to get to
experience these things anyway it's a long time coming but
we're finally gonna have donation reading time yeah it's
been it's been 20 years but finally doki will read her
donations i'm sorry there was so many things going on but
it's finally here i have time all right let's see okay i
need to do like let me make sure there's an outline though
so there is an outline for us wait what color can i can i
not change the outline oh that i can i say what the fuck why
can't i change the outline color um guys sorry it's been
like a while since i've had like uh there we go yeah
donation reading time wait did i hit 750k subscribers oh my
god we have 50k left till it uh the special karaoke and i
also have to finish the fucking climbing game too because i
promised that for 700k oh my god we literally hit exactly
750 oh my god thank you everybody uh for 750k uh subscribers
oh my god and we've like We've... Oh my god, thank you.
It's just crazy to think about.
But we're at 750k now, exactly.
Thank you everybody for subscribing and supporting me.
It's this...
Um...
Next.
So, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But will she read this?
Yes!
I have.
I've just read it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
What's a donation reading?
Guys, I think it's been like months since we had this, so
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
But we're back.
We're looking back, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Matt, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Weird.
I'm on work Wi-Fi, so I'm experiencing the new intro at 240p
just as Tokyo intended.
Thank you, my super chat, thank you, thank you.
JL.
Oh, no, being dragged into retail hell again.
Here we go again.
Thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
Um, uh, thank you for, uh, uh, oh yeah, I think, I hope you
guys like the new intro.
I'm thinking about, like, for the, for future, I would love
to do, like, future intros with just different outfits.
I think that would be really fun.
Like, every time we get a new outfit, we get a new intro.
We're, I think that would be, like, I feel like that would
be, like, be a nice, like, little thing um every time so
like and then like when i'm using that particular outfit
i'll swap to that intro and so then you'll be like oh she's
gonna be using that new outfit today uh so i think i might i
might do that in the future um i saw somebody like when will
there be updates on the discord for the minecraft server
there are a few of us with technical difficulties and we
don't know where to turn it soon um i was supposed to make
it yesterday but then i fell asleep i'm
It will be made either today or tomorrow.
We're going to be implementing the new chat update.
Like either, I think tomorrow.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, speaking of the Minecraft update.
The Minecraft server update.
They are making a coliseum for you guys to fight each other.
So let me show you guys a picture of it.
They actually sent me like an update progress of it.
Where is it?
Where's the Doki server?
Oh my god, here.
I'll show you guys.
right now um so you guys can fight it out so like i said
we're getting like regular we're gonna be getting regular
updates for this look there's gonna be a coliseum guys you
guys are gonna be like press a button and then you're gonna
fight each other and you're gonna spawn in with like
materials like with uh we've already like and then you gotta
do teams too so there's gonna be like teams and stuff for
the battles battle coliseum like this is just whoever wants
to challenge each other and just like fight like you know
brawl it out so this is going to be like one of the first up
like updates that and also the chatting system uh a better
chatting system um so that you can chat with just your
factions or like with particular groups that you started
with um yeah and so like that's like uh that's like one of
the huge updates that we're going to be doing the server
will be up whenever if whenever i finish my other work and i
can make the server today or tomorrow The server will be
made out of today or tomorrow, whenever I have time.
So, don't worry.
We'll get there.
There's a long to-do list.
I made a to-do list, and we're very slowly getting there.
We're almost there.
Haley, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doctor, mmm, yummy CPU.
They give us super chat.
Thank you.
Aqua.
Okay.
We haven't done this in a long time.
But, like...
Aqua, I'm not even going to read your super chat.
But I would say thank you for the super chat.
But there's a reason why we're not going to read your super
chat.
There you go.
all right all right aqua i hope you're i hope like i hope
you know why i'm not reading it um gamina thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you do you plan on going to eva
this year i cannot confirm or deny thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you dream aura thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you first time i've caught a stream
live i just want to say how much i enjoyed your appearance
adobe me hoping for a uk con appearance in the future thank
you Thank you.
Not this year, I feel like.
I don't know if, um, I don't know if there's any, there's,
there's still a few other conventions that haven't been
announced yet, but, um, for this year, uh, but I'm not sure
if UK, I don't think UK is going to be for this year.
next year next year is definitely going to be a lot more
chill when it comes to convention appearance um because like
i said um i booked myself a lot for a lot of different
conventions this year um because i wanted to you know um i
never had the chance to to be able to visit so many
different places around the world in terms of meeting uh my
dragoons so that's why i like went super like hardcore mode
um because like i said yes to a lot i said yes uh to a lot
of places because like i know like there's a lot of places
that never had a chance to meet me in the past and like you
know i'm trying to catch up with lost time with all of you
guys um to be able to like uh have this opportunity because
i don't know if i'm gonna have this opportunity again in the
future uh so that's why i was like yes yes Yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes.
So, for next year, though, I'm definitely going to try to
pick places or conventions maybe that I haven't done before
for next year.
Like, that's going to be my main priority to focus on more
so on, like, places and conventions that I haven't done or,
like, specific conventions that I haven't done before.
That doesn't mean I won't do, like, repeat conventions.
consider repeating some a few conventions um but my priority
is definitely going to be picking new places for next year
um because you know i want to be able to meet as many
dragoons who've never had chance to meet me before you know
like that's like my main goal to be able to meet uh to give
dragoons an opportunity to meet me to like be able to see me
and everything and yeah that's how i want to go on for next
year as well um all right where where am i on my super chats
list oh my god it's been so long i almost forgot what it's
like to read do super chat readings uh um let's see aura
thank you thank you remember to tip your barista they're
doing their best i got paid today so here's my dokey tax
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh cv
miracle thank you Thank you.
Today, no game.
Just chatting.
Dark Blade.
Thank you.
Now I'd win in the Dragon Ball.
See him.
Thank you.
The Super Chat.
Chargo.
Thank you.
Thank you for your Super Chat.
Reptick.
Thank you.
The Super Chat.
Let's see.
Unfried Rice.
Thank you.
Are you a Caramel or Caramel?
Kind of pronounced it.
Caramel.
I pronounce it Caramel the right way.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Brody, wait, we had money for college.
Yeah, we had money for college.
Good catch, good catch.
We're not getting that deposit back, guys.
I don't, I don't, guys, I don't think we're going to get
that deposit back, guys.
Oh my god, did you guys see the Junji Ito Sanrio collab?
Oh my god, I was like, but that was like, that was like one
of the craziest crossovers I've ever seen.
Like, it just, I don't know, did it make it that, okay, it
makes a lot of sense, but also it didn't make a lot of
sense.
It makes a lot of sense because Junji Ito is, um, loves
cats.
Like, he is obsessed with cats.
He has like a, he has like a comedy slice of life, slice,
sorry, slice of life manga.
Um, that's just like dedicated to, like, living with his
cats.
like, like, horrid shit ever.
Yeah.
Okay, uh, guys, it's just, oh my god, it's like a pop-up
story.
Wait, I'll show you guys the picture because I can.
I, I don't know.
I don't know how I feel about it.
Like, I love Junji Ito, and I love Sanrio, but like, I don't
know.
I don't know.
Like, I don't know.
I didn't feel the fun It's definitely like A combo I like
Wait does Cinemora not have eyes Oh my god did they like
What the fuck Oh my god they even oh my god They made what
He has no eyes Wait a minute oh my god Wait this is the
merch Wait he has no eyes Okay look at the merch Wait can I
even can't even drag this No I need to snip it.
I can't drag it.
I can only snip it.
Give me a sec.
It's a web file.
No, not a web file.
Guys, look at this.
I'm going to do this in a morrow.
Why does he have no pupils?
Wait.
Why do the women have pupils?
Like, like, like, God.
Oh my God.
Where are the pupils go?
Holy shit Oh my god Spooky cinnamoro That's so spooky It's
like It's literally a spooky cinnamoro Wait what the fuck I
just Oh my god Wait What the fuck I just noticed this Oh my
god
I literally, I just noticed that.
Oh my god.
Um, yeah, they added, they added the Two-Face Lady.
I was, what the fuck?
They added, they added the Two-Face Lady.
Yeah, they added her.
Um, Akayoni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just want to take the chance to thank you again for coming
to Anime North Tokyo.
It was my first convention ever.
special thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm
glad that it made it feel um super special and honestly like
i love uh meeting all my dragoons during these convention
appearance like i said i try i'm trying to include as many
different places as possible because i know like uh for a
lot of you guys i'm sorry i'm sorry self-america i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry
Spam your convention organizers to invite me But I'm trying
my best to like Include as many places as possible So you
guys can come and meet me
But what the I'm just so surprised Like I never expect
Junjiito to collab with Sanrio of all like I don't know it's
such a it's such a wild collab in general for me because
it's like it's like it's such it's just I I get like hello
kitty but still it's still like it's a collab I never
expected um it's gonna I don't I don't know Junjiito has a
lot of really crazy fans like as in like Junji like the fans
are incredibly fanatic about Junjiito um but they I don't I
guess like I mean I like Junjiito and I like Sanrio but like
I would never expected them to do a collab together um so
it's it's quite it's quite uh I was just really surprised I
don't know how to explain it I was like whoa
Let's see Nevi, thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you Hey Doki, I'm enjoying your Minecraft server I
want to ask if loading houses are allowed On our land Yeah,
yeah, you guys can go wild with your builds Just as long as
it's not like You know, like you're making lag machines or
anything So go wild Also we added a new command in the
Minecraft server If you do slash lobby I think it takes you
to the main lobby the main lobby area so you don't have to
i'm sorry for all the people that travel 10 000 blocks to
get there uh but now you don't uh chid thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i didn't get small on in the
meet and greet raffle for annie rebel but i'll definitely
come to all your public panels there thank you the super
chat thank you thank you don't worry chid there's more than
just a panel And a meet and greet.
That's all I can say.
There might be a special guest.
I don't know if I'm allowed to say that.
But like, whoa.
I might be bringing a special guest with me.
Super Chat.
Thank you.
uh you spoiled a lot what are they gonna do i'm the boss
here i i own my own i guess myself like we're gonna do i'm
the boss
um let's see uh where was that where uh cast thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you why did you write my name
on that cup i didn't order yet thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you uh i'm the company exactly i am the
company uh voyta i'm thinking of the super chat thank you
thank you double restredo venti half soy non-fat decaf
organic chocolate brownie ice vanilla double shot
Gingerbread, frappuccino, extra hot with foam whipped.
You don't...
Is that real?
What's the craziest order that, like, somebody has given
you?
Also, boy, Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's the...
Also, fun.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
What's, like, the...
Any baristas in my chat?
What's the craziest order that, like, a Karen gave you?
What is the craziest order that you had to do?
I'm actually curious.
Like, are these real people?
Like, there's no way.
Where's...
Um, Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
See you in Canada, Doki.
I'm glad to know there would be more than meeting Greece
because I couldn't get an honor.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Alan, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
The raffle was limited.
I'm so sorry.
There's a lot.
Even like, as I know, like the Hyatt booth was also like
raffled as well.
Like the tickets were raffled, but it was so funny seeing
like some of the dragoons that were just looking at the side
because they fenced it off.
It was so funny.
Like they fenced off the booth because they don't want to
overcrowdle the booth area because it could be like, you
know, fire hazard.
So then, but then they had to fence it off during like the
performances.
But I could see like the dragoons like huddled on the side
like looking in they're like I don't have a ticket But I'm
gonna I'm gonna watch it illegally I thought I thought that
was so funny I was staring at you guys be like I'm gonna
watch it illegally
This is really funny I could see you guys on the side Um six
straight expressional shots Jesus Christ That is not healthy
at all.
Let's see.
Absolute.
Thank you.
Aussie knows good coffee.
Wait, what?
They kicked out a coffee shop?
An experience.
Oh, my God.
Australians.
Thank you.
Let's see.
What else?
I'm going to do three more super chats.
And then...
And then we're going to call it here.
Because, like I said, there's a lot to do.
There's a lot to do.
I have a very long to-do list.
But yesterday, I passed out early yesterday.
I've been having like an issue yesterday where I'll be like,
I'm going to take a nap.
And then like I...
It was not a nap.
It's happened way too many times lately.
I'll be like, I'm so tired.
I'm going to take a nap.
And then I wake up and it's like 6 in the morning.
And I'm like, oh no.
And I'm like, maybe I should get up.
And then I'd be like on my phone for two more hours.
And I'll be like, okay, now I should get up.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was nice meeting you at the Don't Get Me panel.
I was able to get into the middle of the group photo.
It's a nice reward after my seven hour trip.
It's almost 1 a.m.
on my side.
So F me for me and the rest of the EU dragons, I guess.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, I really appreciate it.
I'm so happy there's so many EU dragoons during the DoKimi
panel.
I was so surprised because, like, you know, you guys have to
wake up so early or stay up really late for my streams.
So I really, really, really appreciate it, guys.
I'm really happy that a lot of you guys showed up during
DoKimi.
I hope I can have meet and greets too, in the future, uh,
for europe uh conventions um oh my god i'm super excited for
it's gonna be a one-off for the saturday stream for digimon
um because like that game um one of my very first
playstation 1 games was the original digimon world that uh
my dad got me but it was in like japanese so like i had no
idea how to play that game i told the story before but like
um i had no idea how to play what i was doing in that game
but i have a lot of good memories of it because like i just
really love raising the little digimon until they died i
didn't even know how to save my game i didn't know how to
save my digimon world game because it was all in japanese
and then so every time i boot up the game i would just like
restart from the beginning it's basically like basically.
Digimon world is basically like, I don't care about, I'm so
sorry, but I personally, I don't like, I don't really, um, I
don't really like, I don't really care, not like, like, but
my, you know, my preference.
I don't like RPGs, like JRPGs in general.
So like, but I like Digimon world.
Like, I didn't understand what the fuck, like, is going on,
but I like Digimon world.
I could not I could.
It's a long game.
Like Cyber Sluve.
It's a very long because I try to play Cyber Sluve.
Because like I was like okay I need that itch.
I need a scratch Digimon world itch.
I need a yeah Digimon was made was basically the because
Tomagachi was so popular with like girls they made Digimon
to appeal to the guy like to appeal to boys.
Um So, like, to Digimon was, Digimon was practically, like,
the boy version, the male equivalent of, like, Tamagotchi,
um, to, like, yeah, and, yeah, and, um, but, yeah,
basically, like, I've been always trying to scratch that
Digimon world itch, because it's, like, one of my favorite
games, uh, of all time, even though, like, I had zero
understanding about what's going on, um, but I just really
enjoyed playing the game, and I've tried other Digimon
games, I'm sorry, lot of good Digimon games.
I mean, I don't know if you ever watched that video from
like, what's her name?
Jaden Animations.
And she was doing like this whole like, I've been trying to
figure out what's a good Digimon game.
And like, everyone will think differently of what they
consider is a good Digimon game.
Digimon World was my good Digimon game.
And then, um, I've never played the newest version.
This is apparently, like, um, like, I don't, it's not like
a, it's like a sequel to the original Digimon World, and
obviously it has like its own thing too.
Um, so like, uh, it's gonna be a one-off, um, because I
don't think we're ever gonna beat that game i read it's very
hard to beat so it's very grindy because like the digimon
actually dies um if you guys never played it before uh so
like you have like a little time frame to beat the game like
it's because like when they die you you go back from zero
basically so i'm really excited you guys know this but like
uh it's digimon is like is oh my gosh i love i love digimon
more than pokemon i almost say it i i personally love
digimon more than pokemon but like in the west that is like
a different story because most of the digimon content does
not release here do you know do you know where most of the
digimon content is released in it's released in China,
because like people in China love Digimon.
There's so many like exclusives there.
There's so many exclusives there.
And like, oh my God, the merch for it is so good too.
Like it's really like there's a lot of like exclusive merch
made for Digimon and shows and games too.
There's like exclusive games that's just released there and
everything.
um n8 they just don't release digimon stuff in n8 there's
just not big enough fan base i'm just so sad like i wish i
wish the fan base for digimon was bigger
it's just not fair it's not fair what's my favorite digimon
okay this is a joke digimon that's my favorite but like i
love it because i talked about it before but like i love i i
i love i okay okay wait um i his name is bettuman and and
he's based he's an actual digimon and the reason why i love
bettuman because okay that's just like my joke love it's not
my favorite favorite Digimon, but like, he's like my
favorite design because it's so dumb.
He's basically, he's basically like the cosplay Digimon.
Like, he's literally the cosplay Digimon because...
Anyway, um, this is my favorite Digimon design of all the
time because i i just think it's it's funny i just think
it's really funny um but yeah my favorite digimon it's like
uh gatomon terrier mon uh i don't like patamon i'm sorry i i
i don't think i like i know everyone's like but patamon is
like basically like the digimon pikachu i Padamon's ugly
I think Padamon's ugly Okay Anyway I think Gabumon Was one
of my favorites too But then like I said Gabumon was ruined
for me When I realized like How dare you I am gonna say it
again I think Padamon is ugly I think it looks like a
fucking naked mole rat With wings on his head Anyway I used
to like Gobbleman But then I've realized that like He has
He's like basically like a lizard Wearing a skinned Digimon
on top of him And then like there's like Ooh, this is what
Gabumon might look like without it.
And I'm like, Ah.
And then, like, I stopped loving Gabumon.
I could never love him again.
Um, but for those who don't know, I showed this on stream
before, but this is what Gabumon could look like without,
without the, without his, like, pelt on.
I'm just like, Ugh.
Ugh, brother.
Ugh.
Anyway.
But yes.
And I like.
Oh, I like the.
I like.
I like all of.
I think peak design.
Gen.
Gen 3.
Gen 3 Digimon.
Peak design.
Digimon Tamers.
All of.
them except for the little like imp guy uh peak designs i'm
sorry i don't know anybody that actually likes that guy like
does he want to tamer's best designs overall but like except
for that fucking imp guy whoever i forgot his name but like
imp mod people love imp mod i'm not one of them i think
You can say he's a good character.
Alright, I'll say he's a good character.
But like, I hate his design.
Like, you can't... I don't care.
He might be the best...
Maybe, like, one of the best character developed...
Character developed Digimon in the show.
But, like, I just don't like his design.
I'm sorry.
Like, I just don't like his design.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your tomato without your skin.
Yeah, but at least I look hot as a tomato.
At least I don't have a double chin as a tomato.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No name.
It's just all head.
head um let's see um what does that want to say what does
that want to say um but yeah i wish there was more digimon
content in um in the west but uh it's just not popular
enough because like pokemon has such a monopoly pokemon has
such a monopoly here that like it's so hard for digimon to
like do anything like which sucks it sucks because like i
just i like the designs more i think digimon has better
designs i honestly think digimon designs look a lot better
than like pokemon designs like they have guns for arms
that's so badass
They had You'll never see a Pokemon With a gun Blade Thank
you for the Thank you for the magenta super Thank you Thank
you Digimon Frontier It's the one that is like Power Rangers
Mixed with Mixed with Digimon Is that the one that like
Sucked?
Oh Sorry Blade Thank you My magenta super Thank you Um I
personally I like Had no like I didn't hate Digimon Frontier
but like Digimon Frontier like killed the franchise in the
west apparently I because there's no actual Digimon it was
just kids like it was no actual Digimon it's like they are
the Digimon I'm like I don't fucking care about them as the
Digimon I didn't I want I want I want real did I like I
didn't hate Digimon Frontiers I was like I didn't like hate
it I was just like I was okay with it obviously like they
had to follow after Tamers and Tamers was like the shit like
Tamers was like basically like hardcore like Digimon while
Pokemon was still like Ash is still 10 and like still like
Ash is still 10 and like death isn't real in the Pokemon
Like, people die in Tamers.
So, like...
And then Digimon Tamers came out, and they're like, Death's
real, yo.
Digimon can die!
I was like, what the fuck?
And I was like, little...
I was a little child.
I was just like, what the fuck?
You mean, Death is real?
73 Thank you Thank you With the super chat Thank you Thank
you Congrats on your guest invitation For ACG HK and
sponsorship I'm excited for earning These awesome
Opportunities Thank you for the super chat Thank you Me too
I'm really happy I'm so happy to Experience it with you guys
too Let's see Pug Thank you for the super chat Thank you
Thank you uh deputy mon and uh gun drum on our peak designs
change my mind pug thank you the super chat thank you thank
you oh true he's like a natural gun yeah for those who don't
know deputy mon is literally gun wait i forgot about that
but yeah pokemon would never
okay for those who don't know what what and deputy mon look
i forgot about deputy he might.
That makes him so cool.
He's so cool.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Anyway, where was I?
I'm looking at Deputy Mining it.
Okay.
That's just that that's That's peak Digimon right there.
What about Gundramon?
Was Gundramon the one with, like, all guns?
Is that it?
Uh...
Let's see.
Oh, my God!
Oh, I remember.
I remember Gundramon.
I remember being...
Like, never mind.
I...
I remember...
Guys, I remember what Gundramon looks like, guys.
I remember that.
Okay, for those who don't know what Gundramon looks like,
this is...
This is Gundramon.
This is more gun.
Right here.
This is...
This is Gundramon.
Anyway.
I wish...
I wish there was more Digimon.
I really do.
I love Digimon so much.
But there's just not enough Digimon content.
Like there's nothing we can do.
I mean...
That's the American Oh my gosh I remember Where you guys are
the What stream was it What oh it was with Hero Yeah it's so
funny I think my favorite I always love how like When I talk
about Digimon To like other people Who just like Who live
like in Asia And all they know about Digi Like you know like
The Digimon opening Is like butterfly I've never heard of
Like I told you guys I've never heard about butterfly Until
like like you know like i think like like um uh maybe like
uh maybe like within like seven years that's when like i
heard about butterfly but like i grew up with digimon
digital monsters
like that's like i like the japanese opening for digimon
And, like, people were like, oh, it's, like, the most famous
Japanese opening of all time.
Like, it's one of the, that's one of the most famous, um,
anime openings.
And I was like, what?
I think, oh, yes!
The first time I've ever heard Butterfly was when they did
the movie reboot.
The movie reboot were Thai, were, like, adults slash
teenagers or some shit.
And then, so, like, they had a thing where, like, the
Digimon Tamers, um, the Digimon Tamers were singing the
opening of Butterfly.
And that was the very first time I heard Butterfly.
Because I was like, what the fuck?
Whoa, that's such a great song.
I'll be like, wow, I can't believe this movie made this
song.
It's so good.
Like, little did I know it came from the TV show.
show opening.
Yeah, I'm sorry, a DigiDestin.
Like, I was like, I'd be like, whoa, I can't believe, like,
I can't believe they made this song for this movie.
And, like, I was like, wow, I can't believe DigiDestin.
Wow, they got the DigiDestins to sing a song for this movie.
Whoa.
And that was the first time I've ever heard, um, that's
literally the first time i've ever heard butterfly um
because of the movie um because i grew up with with the
digimon digital monsters digimon and you're the champions
like but that shit still slaps though that shit slaps man
and then when you tell them about yeah we had our own
opening they'll be like what the fuck i'll be like what do
you mean you have your own english opening is it as good as
butterfly and i'm just be like um yeah you can say that it
was catchy it was a catchy opening like that's that's
something to be fair like we always like made up lyric like
i missed a time when we like made up openings for like anime
because like um do you guys know how like the sailor moon
opening is like super iconic the english one is like uh
fighting was it fighting evil by moonlight oh my gosh what
was oh my god i haven't heard the sailor moon opening in so
long um but like the english opening they made up words they
made up words for it.
Uh, it wasn't even like...
It had nothing to do with the original opening.
It's the same melody, but it's a different...
It's not...
It had nothing to do with the original Japanese opening.
It's the same melody.
The lyrics don't...
The lyrics had no connection with the original song, which I
thought was really funny.
I'm going to look at the I'm trying to remember Okay, the
Jet Moonlight Because like the original lyrics The original
lyrics It was like Okay, let me see it Translation English
Let me see The original lyrics was a Was a romantic song It
was literally a song about like Like romance and stuff like
it was a love song it was literally a love song um
um but yeah it was it's i thought it was like pretty funny
um yeah this is a miracle of romance i'm reading the lyrics
right now uh like look at this it's actually crazy easy it's
so it's so funny like rereading this yeah and it's like the
original Sailor Moon opening and we just made up we just
made up English lyrics because it sounded good Sailor Moon
English lyrics opening English theme song yeah it's just
like fighting evil by moonlight winning love by daylight
never running from a real fight she is the one name seller
moon and and then you fucking read this and it's like it's
hard for me to say although it's easy to say in my dreams my
thought circuit is about to break down you know right now i
want you with me that's like what it was supposed to be like
that's that's the original lyric
in the yeah i thought it was hilarious that's not an intro
um anyway that was a nice sorry i forgot to do super chat
reading part because i started uh i start we had a long
tangent but anyway i'm gonna call it here i'm calling here
everybody uh i always have great time hanging out with you
guys um as always every everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and
if you stay up from me head to bed because you deserve it
i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye